okay this next story is so sordid and
bizarre and so disturbing that I
struggled with exactly how to lay it out
for you in the simplest and clearest
terms and the clearest way is actually
not chronologically it's almost
backwards and then coming back to the
present so last week or the week before
we learned that New England Patriots the
football team the New England Patriots
the owner Bob Kraft was arrested for
soliciting prostitution at a spa in
Florida and we know that Donald Trump is
good friends with Bob Kraft he said he
was surprised and saddened by the news
about Kraft soliciting prostitution okay
then we learned that the spa massage
parlor where this took place which is
now called orchids of Asia Day Spa has
been implicated not only in prostitution
but potentially in a sex trafficking
ring now this is actually a sex
trafficking ring this is unlike pizza
gate or whatever else this is actually
maybe a sex trafficking operation
according to what authorities are saying
it used to be owned by a 45 year old
Chinese woman named Li yang and that's
the second connection to Donald Trump
for this story because Kraft was busted
there and Kraft his Trump's friend Li
yang used to own it and Li yang happened
to watch the Super Bowl with Donald
Trump at the White House recently okay
but fine no big deal because even though
Li yang knows Trump now and she doesn't
own the place and she insists she never
did anything illegal her presence with
Trump is mere coincidence it doesn't
really matter Trump is in pictures with
millions of people as Sarah Huckabee
Sanders has previously told us except
that Li yang has moved from running
massage parlor spas to selling access to
the Trump family to Chinese
businesspeople now li yang who goes by
Cindy yang I'll call her that for the
rest of the story she and her husband
run a company called Gy US Investments
LLC they've done that since 2017 and
this is a consulting firm which helps
businesses in the United States
expand in the Chinese market place but
interestingly they also help Chinese
businesses make high-level connections
in the United States that starts to get
a little bit more interesting they have
pictures of trumps Florida Mara Lago
Resorts and they list that they have
activities for clients which include
getting the opportunity to interact with
the president's as well as the Minister
of Commerce guessing they mean the
Secretary of Commerce and other
political figures and they can also help
you set up White House and Capitol Hill
dinners they are selling access to the
upper echelons of power in the United
States including the closest thing we
have to a royal family right now Trump
and his family the day that this story
broke all of a sudden the G Y us
Investments website stopped working all
of this material connecting them to
Donald Trump has been pulled down off of
the Internet
we've been researching Cindy yang and it
turns out that she's a member of the
president's presidential fundraising
committee she donated a total of sixty
thousand dollars to Donald Trump and to
a PAC that supports him her Facebook
page was filled with pictures of her and
Don jr.
and congressman Matthew gates who's a
big trump supporter and Elaine Chao the
wife of Senate Minority of Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell and
Sarah Palin except that if you try to
find that Facebook page now it has also
been taken down as the scope of this
Fiasco has continued to expand and
before the gyu s investments website was
taken down it had a long list of events
at mar-a-lago where you can mingle with
Trump or his family members here's one
such promotion saying that you can hang
out with Donald Trump's sister during
the recent government shutdown
Donald Trump was scheduled to go hang
out with these Chinese business people
but the trip was canceled over the
shutdown and Donald Trump ended up
staying in Washington DC but the
business model here is very clear the
same woman who previously ran a massage
parlor which is now tied up in a
prostitution sex trafficking
we're Bob Kraft Trump's friend and owner
of the Patriots was arrested they are
selling access to Trump and his family
here's a picture of tang wha a president
of some kind of automotive Verve firm in
China with Eric Trump we have a picture
of Don Jr with another Chinese business
person in addition to Tang hua and
before her Facebook page was taken down
Cindy yang had multiple check ins at the
White House at mar-a-lago at Trump
International DC hotels at Trump's
national golf course at Trump Tower New
York City it is stunning
so the headline here is that the person
who used to own the illegal massage
parlor where Trump friend Bob Kraft was
arrested for soliciting prostitution is
now running a business that sells access
to Trump's family this is a massive
major story if Barack Obama had been
involved in 5% of this on mere
circumstance and suspicions alone the
right would be calling for his
impeachment but there are lots of other
important stories here as well that go
beyond just the Trump cronyism and
corruption there's a national security
angle here we know that there is
significant Chinese infiltration with
American businesses and there are
security concerns here this is a story
of course about crony capitalism but
it's also about how you can buy access
to the President of the United States
but these Chinese consulting firms are
so often mixed in with Chinese
intelligence services and being able to
so easily buy access to the president
and his family at mar-a-lago is a
national security risk
and then lastly with the massage parlor
prostitution spa portion of the entire
thing there's also the story of the
legalization of sex work which is
another issue which we've discussed
before but that's the story in its full
scope it requires a whole suite of new
investigations which we might get but at
this point the investigative capacity of
our institutions is stretched almost to
the max and I wonder whether there's
even going to be a
proper and full investigation into this
we know Republicans are under no urgency
to do such an investigation let me know
what you think about this I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show
and I'll be back with much more right
after this one of the day's sponsors is
privacy dot-com slash Pakman which is a
free service that I myself use really
useful in many different ways takes just
a few seconds to link your debit card to
privacy calm then you can create virtual
credit cards that are linked directly to
your bank account and you use those
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online which protects your actual
debit card so that it's not spread all
over the internet and one of the best
things about it is how their mobile app
and browser extensions for Chrome and
Firefox make it really easy to use let's
say for example that I'm signing up for
a David Pakman show membership in the
credit card number field I already see
the privacy com icon I just click it
choose which of my virtual credit cards
I want to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link